[Música]
recuerdo cuando daba clases de
matemáticas de nivel media superior o
preparatoria en baja california el más
de una ocasión cuando teníamos que
trazar en la clase alguna línea recta
para un triángulo un pentágono un
cuadrilátero y los estudiantes no traían
su regla improvisaban utilizaban una
pluma como referencia utilizaban una
calculadora utilizaban una credencial
buscaban cómo lograr esta línea recta de
alguna manera lo lograban y funcionaba
esta improvisación sin embargo si
estábamos en una materia donde tenían
que medir o hacer unidades por ejemplo
en el plano cartesiano esta creatividad
esta improvisación ya no funcionaba del
todo esto es lo que yo observo en las
clases en línea de un día para otro
tuvimos que cambiar una dinámica de
clase a clases en línea entonces se tuvo
que improvisar los maestros padres de
familia no estaban entendiendo por qué
los estudiantes no ponían la misma
atención porque ellos seguían utilizando
las mismas estrategias que en un salón
de clases tradicional
se iban a ver rebasados por esta
improvisación que estaban haciendo y
aquí es donde uno se puede preguntar
habría la forma de que ahora el
estudiante sea el que persiga al maestro
o al padre de familia en lugar como está
sucediendo ahorita que los padres de
familia los maestros buscan como los
estudiantes se pongan a estudiar se
pongan a ver vídeos o utilicen algún
otro recurso será esto posible como
youtuber te puedo decir que sí pero
antes de decirte la explicación concreta
déjame platicarte un poco mi historia yo
empecé a hacer vídeos desde el 2009 con
mi socia cookies allá en tijuana y fue
por una situación de que queríamos
ayudar a unos estudiantes que iban de un
concurso regional de baja california a
sonora entonces la solución fue subir
vídeos para que cada quien estudiará a
su ritmo porque yo no podía prepararlos
en aquel entonces porque estaban en
diferentes ciudades en el estado cada
quien estaba diferente horario y la
solución fue subir vídeos a youtube
hacerlo nos dimos cuenta que se abría
pues como que nuevas oportunidades cada
estudiante podía estudiar a su ritmo
cuando quisiera y donde quisiera después
no subimos solamente vídeos de concursos
nos dimos cuenta que las personas pedían
inesperadas realmente porque iban para
ciertos estudiantes estos vídeos de
otras partes porque no subes temas de
pitágoras de fracciones y les hicimos
caso empezamos a subir vídeos de estas
materias y nos dimos cuenta que las
personas después empezaban a comentar
decían pasé mi examen ahora porque no
subes otro tema y les empezamos también
hacer caso entonces esta oportunidad de
que las personas pudieran estudiar a su
ritmo era algo que ya estaba en nuestras
manos algo que podíamos aportar en lo
personal yo tuve muy buenos maestros en
el salón de clase a mí me inspira van a
tener muy buenas calificaciones de hecho
a que amar a las matemáticas de cierta
manera pero personas que estuvieran
maestros haciendo clases en línea
2009 yo no miraba a tantos de hecho de
los que yo conocía no después me enteré
al estar subiendo vídeos a youtube que
existían otras personas con el mismo
interés de subir vídeos para que las
personas estudiarán a su ritmo y las
veces que quisieran porque yo también
como maestro me empecé a dar cuenta que
no tenía sentido que yo repitiera una
clase por ejemplo los elementos de la
circunferencia de la parábola en un
salón de clases terminaba mi clase me
iba a otra y tenía que volverlos a
repetir yo decía bueno porque no los
grabó en un vídeo se lo repito o les
pido que lo vean en su casa o los llevo
al audiovisual que sí lo hice en su
momento y ya podía destinar el tiempo
restante de la clase para otra actividad
por ejemplo a hacer ejercicios a
enfocarme con los estudiantes que
tuvieran pues menos desempeño y a los
que más pues decirle que me ayudarán con
los que no bueno hacer otra dinámica ya
mi rol como docente miraba que podía
cambiar al tener este material en línea
así que continuamos haciendo vídeos
cookies y yo a mí me gustan mucho las
matemáticas no sé mucho sobre
en aquel entonces producción iluminación
que cámara tenía que utilizar que
programa sin embargo aceptamos el reto
nos capacitamos hicimos prueba y error
porque sabíamos que la recompensa de
tener estos vídeos en línea era pues
todo realmente ver que los estudiantes
te digan profe su vídeo me sirvió y en
unos minutos pude entender el tema hacer
mi tarea de hecho eso fue lo que empecé
a hacer desde desde el 2009 subía mis
clases y parte si estaba dando en el
salón de clases pero los estudiantes que
no venían ya no había pretexto de que
como no vinieron la clase no la
entendieron no la vieron no estaba en
línea así que les pedía un resumen ya
venían e íbamos avanzando de otra manera
esto es algo que a mí me cambió la forma
de ver las clases mi rol como docente si
yo tenía la oportunidad de aportar
contenido en línea lo tenía que hacer
era una oportunidad que se me había
presentado y no podía dejar de hacerlo
así que continuamos haciendo vídeos
cookies y yo ella es comunicólogo y me
estuvo
orientando como puede ser un poco más
humano porque la conexión en las redes
sociales la conexión cuando subes un
vídeo a internet porque uno está aquí a
través de una cámara y de cierta manera
es algo frío cuando uno tiene a los
estudiantes en el salón de clases puedes
ver sus caras y funciona algo lo puedes
ver y si no funciona también lo ves pero
en una en un vídeo no la situación es
diferente así que entre cookies y yo
estábamos creando un modelo de enseñar a
distancia para que los estudiantes
pudieran estudiar a su ritmo después al
estar subiendo vídeos también te das
cuenta de ciertas características tú no
sabes si las personas son hombres
mujeres no sabes qué idiomas qué idioma
hablan no sabes cuál es su religión no
sabes en qué país están y todo esto lo
debes de tener en cuenta cuando tú creas
un vídeo tampoco sabes cuánto tiempo lo
van a ver y si puedes resolverles su
problema si no te lo van a expresar es
lo que te empiezas a dar cuenta que se
va creando una comunidad te va empezando
a formar como docente en línea hay que
hacerles caso
yo les hice caso y me ayudaron mucho a
cambiar aspectos como la forma de
explicar a un ritmo porque yo me
emociono mucho hablando de matemáticas
pero luego me decían profe bajeles de
revoluciones o suba le de revoluciones o
no se enfoque tanto a la demostración
mejor vaya directo a los ejercicios yo
sé que soy estudiante pero quiero pasar
mi examen es lo que me interesa y mejor
en otro vídeo haga la justificación o
demostración y todo esto lo fui
entendiendo para juntar el interés de
los estudiantes y lo que a mí también me
apasiona que es enseñar las matemáticas
de que iba a servir que estuviera
dedicando tiempo a la creación de
contenidos cuando al final no iba a
poder provocar el objetivo de que los
estudiantes pudieran pasar su examen
entonces esto fui aprendiendo lo hay al
ir subiendo los vídeos y otra cuestión
muy importante que aprendí como u2 ver
que lo sigo aprendiendo es que nunca te
preguntan si estudiaste una maestría si
estudiaste un doctorado en educación no
no no no realmente las credenciales es
lo último que preguntan en redes
sociales o en youtube
simplemente si funciona funciona y se ve
muy transparente si comentan si le ponen
likes si tiene buenas visitas si tienen
buenas visitas obviamente esto es tu
calificación esta es tu credibilidad por
lo tanto me enfocaba a crear contenidos
de cierta manera cada vez más apegados a
la necesidad de los estudiantes a mi
comunidad y esto pues lograba que la
gente los compartiera y ahorita te puedo
comentar que en el 2021 ya tenemos más
de 450 millones en todas las visitas de
los vídeos que tenemos que el día de hoy
son 3000 en el canal de youtube de mass
to me pero no solamente está y se acaba
este camino de edu ver también la parte
de la duración de los vídeos yo puedo
decir como maestro de un salón de clases
tienen que durar 50 minutos tienen que
durar 45 minutos acá el tiempo también
la misma plataforma la misma comunidad
te va moldeando no todos los temas
tienen que ser largos no todos los temas
tienen que ser de 5 minutos de 10 de 15
de 20
y esto lo vas aprendiendo cuando vas
subiendo vídeos y te van dando
retroalimentación de ahí que en las
clases en línea yo veo que los maestros
dan clases de 50 minutos cuando no han
medido cuando no han preguntado si
quieren quedarse todo este tiempo los
estudiantes yo sé que el sistema si está
creado pero realmente no me cabe en la
cabeza que tengamos que estar durando 50
45 minutos a través de una clase en
línea de hecho otra parte importante
como youtube es entender tus métricas
entender que las redes sociales pues
tiene una tecnología tal que te puede ir
rápidamente diciendo qué cosas haces
bien y qué cosas haces mal en caso que
tu comunidad no lo haga entonces si la
comunidad no lo hace la tecnología que
tiene la plataforma en este caso youtube
o en otras te lo dice hay que aprender a
estudiarlas hay que aprender a
entenderlas hay que saber qué vídeo
funciona en cuanto a las visitas a los
likes porque a veces las personas se
fijan nada más en las visitas o en las
vistas en los primeros días pero yo la
verdad
educativo no no espero mucho realmente
yo veo unas ciertas métricas que yo
puedo predecir bajo mi el comportamiento
de años del canal de mark to meet que lo
aprendido poder predecir si ese vídeo
funcionar o no en un futuro casi siempre
los contenidos educativos no son
explosivos a diferencia de un contenido
de comedia o de otro tipo de
entretenimiento pero aquí si algo tú ves
que va a funcionar siempre por ejemplo
un tema de fracciones va a ser
recurrente el tema de pitágoras el tema
de ecuaciones lineales y si lo haces
bien créeme que él solito va a ser
explosivo no te tienes que preocupar así
que las métricas han sido algo muy
importante la comunidad también entender
que tú impactos de cierta manera a
personas de forma directa en sus
estudios y alguno dirá profe pues cuánto
le lleva a hacer un vídeo si lleva su
tiempo sin embargo la recompensa las
repeticiones que le pueden dar al vídeo
pues lo pagan automáticamente pagan tu
tiempo pagan todo
de hecho esto también es lo que me
gustaría cerrar como u2 ver si te puedes
dar cuenta aquí pues si funciona a mí en
lo personal me cambió la vida me hizo
entender mi rol como maestro digital y
que me inspira día a día a levantarme y
decir tengo que crear una clase que
cambie esa condición de las matemáticas
o de otras materias a las personas que
están creyendo en los contenidos demás
tú me así que a mí me funcionó utilizar
la tecnología para cambiar la forma de
enseñar las matemáticas entendiendo la
utilizándola correctamente y funciona
así que yo te invito maestro que utiliza
la tecnología correctamente para que
también cambies toda esta dinámica de
clases en línea para mejorar ese ese
futuro de los estudiantes que está del
otro lado de la cámara así que acepté el
reto maestro que está al alcance de un
clic
[Aplausos]